Hello
最近我身邊的人都對這個AI Agent挺好奇的
然後甚至有人花了幾千塊錢去買課啊之類的
然後也有朋友問我究竟怎麼要使用AI Agent啊之類的
之类的
然后所以我觉得我可以稍微分享一下
我是怎么使用的
就是作为一个普普通通的程序员
我是怎么样用AI agent的
其实我真正用AI agent也是从OpenClaw
火了之后
我才真正开始搭自己的AI agent
嗯
其实作为普通人
把agent用起来是很快的
而且只需要给agent一些基础的能力
很基础的能力
他就能够帮你提升不少效率
这是我这么感觉的
然后呢这期视频不是一个教程
他只是
我只是想要通过这个视频讲一下我是怎么使用的
所以呢
就是这样的
我一般
其实现在AI agent
我认为啊就是
比较主流的
就三个
就是说
当然AI agent有很多类型啊
例如腾讯的Workbody
或者Manus
那是另外一类AI agent
甚至Claw Desktop
他们是另外一类
就是有完整的交互界面的AI agent
但是我今天聊的呢
或者是我平时使用的呢
是没有的
没有交互界面的
它不是腾讯Workbody那种
它
我先把那个
先翻一下墙
然后
现在主流的
我认为就三个
一个就是claw
对吧
也是claw
然后呢
一个是clawdex
skip
先不更新
然后呢
还有一个就是
opencode
其实就是这三个
我觉得
但你用任何一个是没有任何关系的
唯一的影响是什么呢
Claw
大家都知道
可能都听过
它很容易封号
所以它也不太容易
在国内不是那么容易
能够订阅的了
然后Codex呢
稍微好一点
但它也是个国外的模型
然后你要买它
可能稍微也是麻烦一点
然后至于OpenCode什么呢
OpenCode就是一个
你可以接任何大模型
基本像国产的那种
质谱啊
minimax啊
kimi啊
dipsick啊都可以
当然像这些大模型
他们也提供了
claw code
适配的end point
的
接口
甚至是codex适配的接口
都ok
所以而且这是其实没有太大关系的
就是如果你不是用它来写代码
这个问题其实不大的
然后呢
OK 这是第一个前提
就是你要有这么一个东西在你的命令行里面启动
然后第二个东西呢
就是
你需要有一个稳定的地方
存一些东西
然后这个东西可能是你的一些
这就很个人化了
就例如在这里我放了user.md
然后列了一些我的主要目标
然后我是一个什么人
我现在处于一个什么状态
但可能你不需要这些
然后还有就是我的股票持仓
就例如你想让你的agent做什么
你想他成为一个什么样的agent
你就给他什么样的讯息就好了
然后还有我用我的agent来管理我的代办事项
所以我还有一个todo
然后另外呢
还有一个叫bring dumb的一个文件夹
里面放了很多
我让我的agent去记录一些我稍重机事的一些想法
然后还有一些
还有像什么美国签证材料
就这种各种东西
然后还有一些调研的报告什么的
然后就是像我让这个agent帮我去做一些什么研究
然后我让他把这东西存起来
就这么一个地方
ok 这是第二点
就是说你要有一个地方让他存东西
然后第三点
就是你让这个agent有联网的能力
然后这个联网的能力呢
不是说简单的
就是他可以用
他可以网上搜点东西
而是说让他能够使用你的浏览器
就OK了
我举个例子
我现在用任求一个都无所谓
我用claw code
把这关掉
claw code例如我跟大家说
我一般喜欢用语音转文字
我就跟他说
去小红书搜一下
看现在美国签证
缅面签续签
有什么注意事项
还有什么坑是大家遇到的
然后当然现在其实包括
包括那个小红书自己也有他的AI
你也不一定要这样去问
你的agent
我只做一个演示
就是告诉你agent有联网的能力
他可以帮你去搜寻东西
并且归纳总结东西
然后他就像
他在用我的那个brave浏览器
我先打开看一下
ok然后这是
这应该是他的操作
我是没有做任何操作的
然后
他说找到了164个bc
然后各种
哦
他没法点开这个页面
可能是被小龙叔给
拦截了
然后他说哦
直接访问这个URL是不行的
然后他会怎么做呢
他可能会换一种方法去做
因为他需要看笔记内容
对吧
這個可能需要的時間會久一點
他終於看到了,剛才一閃而過了
他已經看完冰盤那個筆記給關掉了
OK,然後你可以看到左上角這裡,他又看了下一篇文章,他一直在看新文章,然後你看,一直在看,然後這就是他在代替你做調研,
然后
这个其实我们有时候用那个
什么deep seek啊
或者是豆包啊
它有联网能力
对不对
但是作为你的个人AI agent
活在你的电脑里面呢
它有一个优势
是它可以使用你
真实浏览器去访问东西
并且它有登录状态
它有我的登录状态
那这样子像小红书
像X
或者像类似的一些
其他的封闭的网站
他也可以去访问
而且没那么容易被触发反爬虫
并且
OK他已经做完调研了
然后他自动把这个
Ulan窗口给关掉
OK然后这就是他的一些
结论
然后一些坑blahblahblah
材料
只带几样
多焦反而坏事
大家踩过具体的坑
照片不能和护照上的一样
哦
然后
OK就是这样
然后甚至最后他说
他建议要不要把这些细节都放在我那个笔记里面
因为其实我之前就已经有跟他在聊过这个事情
甚至当时我填那个签证事情表的时候呢
我有很多东西不懂
我是一边跟他在聊
一边去填
一边他网上搜资料
一边教我怎么做
所以我们之前已经有过一些积累了
然后他现在建议要不要把这些新的坑也写进去
其实就这样
在我看来
你只需要给这两个能力给agent
第一个
就是给他一个稳定的可以存东西的地方
然后他每次开启新绘画
他都能够稳定的抓取
第二点
就是给他联网的能力
就已经能够帮你做很多事情了
其实我是想要做一期稍微小白一点的视频
但是我知道其实就算是这样
可能也会有门槛
不过可能假如这个东西有人看的话
我接下来会再做一期更小白的
或者是更深入的视频
先这样吧
拜拜